ok, nous sommes à 116
miles, euh, c'est un champ assez grand
ici ouais, nous avons besoin d'un gros patchwork
de champs juste pour montrer
que nous sommes aux États-Unis et non en
France, des terriers de lapin sur le
S
ouais
en passant par là,
c'est ça faire  ça, je vais juste
continuer, continuer, faire, ouais,
ouais, mets autant d'efforts que tu peux ici,
je veux dire, c'est
ouais, ouais, ça
donne plus de graphiques ici,
ouais,
les motifs sont meilleurs que ceux d'
avant, je continue comme dans  ça
ouais tu es sur
le bâton sur ces PC plutôt que d'aller là-
bas vers les trucs de l'UNF je suis toujours en train de
grimper ouais c'est bien ouais garde juste
une minute ouais ouais
mes jambes commencent à se fatiguer ouais,
tu iras bien, n'est-ce pas  Ne t'inquiète pas merci il
y a tellement de sincérité dans ton
réconfort quel était ce mot tu
m'as dit à propos du mot de femme merdique
Oher oh ouais aux États-Unis on dit
[ __ ] oh ouais
je le savais je cherchais le monde
ouais désolé pour
ça  tous les sons enregistrés
[ __ ] oh eh bien oh eh bien maintenant le mot est sorti
et comme tu ne le pensais pas, peu
importe comment tu appelles un producteur de merde,
une
[ __ ] qui va écouter
ça toi moi tout
va bien très
bien c'est  très
bien, vois toutes ces routes carrées, regarde
ici, regarde ça, tu peux oh ouais oh
ouais, ils sont écrits sur le GPS
tu as chaque champ sur ton GPS ouais et
bien ce que j'ai, c'est chaque route, chaque
route carrée hé, il a une route, il  il n'a pas
le terrain il a une
route oh ok tu
sais les gars ça a l'air basé sur là ouais
ça a l'air mieux j'essaye je vole
donc je ne m'aligne sur aucune
route juste ouais juste pas de route
principale
quoi quoi
ha
Voir l'
angle de lumière ah un peu de
rouge brun puis-je
bien savoir à quelle hauteur sommes-nous 2 8 000 réglés
nous sommes à environ
5 000 du sol environ 30 nous sommes à environ
4 500 du
sol Je grimpe toujours
pour la piscine ptic
Alarme de pierre jaune plus
ouais  ok ok eh bien je vais bien je pense que
nous avons
fini